A lot of girls,
like, don't eat for two days
if they wanna have anal sex.
Two whole days for anal?!
It's not worth it.
I won't do it.
-What the hell?
-No... two days?
-I won't do it, and I love...
-Who has the strength
for anal after you've starved
yourself? You need to...
- That's a good...
- Adriana Chechik?
Oh, that's a good point.
Yeah, you, you do, you...
A lot of girls...
I remember one of
my friends was like,
"I'm having anal tonight
for the first time.
I haven't... I've been drinking
clear soup for two days."
I'm like, "That sucks.
I will not..."
Is it -- Ramadan for your ass?
Yeah.
(laughter)
If you could just time your
anal around Ramadan...
-Yeah.
-...that would actually be
really good.
♪ Go! ♪
♪♪
Myka Fox is here,
a friend of the show,
a hilarious bitch,
my kinda doppelganger.
I'm, you know, tooting
my own horn by saying that.
(chuckles)
Let's toot both horns,
let's toot a few.
Yeah, like...
Is that what we were just
talking about?
Yeah.
(laughter)
We were just talking
about farts off-air, guys.
We're gonna get
back into it, but, uh...
Myka has a weekly show,
"Live from Outer Space,"
in Bushwick,
at the Cobra Club,
if you're in New York City.
Um, where is that?
What time... when is it?
It's at 9:00 p.m.,
it's off the Jefferson L stop.
Ian's gonna be on the next one.
-Yeah, Friday night.
-What day of the week
are we looking at?
That's a Friday night.
Every Friday night.
Fridays nights, okay.
-Best weekly in town.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, it's really fun.
-Very cool, very hip.
-Oh...
-Yeah.
If I call it cool.
-I'm in town this Friday.
-Oh...
-You're on it this Friday?
-Yeah.
-Come do it.
-Maybe I'll stop in
and say "Hey."
But I just
don't go to Brooklyn
ever, ever, ever now.
Come to Brooklyn! Yeah!
But I'm gonna be doing spots
in the city on Friday night.
-You know, like,...
-Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to, like, really
stack 'em up.
-Yeah.
-Get ready for my special
taping, which is May 22nd,
everyone.
-Ooh.
-May 22nd. Make sure that
you're in Los Angeles May 22nd.
Build a trip around it.
I don't know
what day of the week it is,
I think it's either
a Tuesday or a Wednesday,
but May 22nd is the date
that I'm taping my Netflix
special in Los Angeles,
all details coming up, um,
soon as I can get 'em.
It is a Wednesday.
And we're gonna
have some fun and...
there'll be two shows
to go to that night,
tickets will be available,
they'll be free,
uh, make sure
you make it out, but, um...
So, Myka and Ian
are here, um...
Yeah, how are you guys?
Good?
-I'm good, yeah.
Yeah, we were just talking
about farts off-air
and discussing whether
or not the sound of a fart
is inspired by the butt cheeks
or inspired...
like, your, your --
is like, "You know what?"
-It has a muse.
-Yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
It's Shakespearean.
...uh, is caused
by butt cheeks or...
-Flapping.
-It's the sphincter.
Or the sphinct.
The kind that's like, "Rrr..."
is when the butt,
the butthole...
What's your favorite
kinda fart?
-The...
-Alone. When you're by yourself.
-...straight up "Brrrn?"
One that asks a question?
(laughing)
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
One that asks a question
that can't be answered.
-Uh-huh. Yeah, yeah.
-You know?
Like, one of those
existential questions.
(laughing)
"Why are we here?"
Yeah.
That kind of question.
Yeah, I like those too.
Like a S... Socrates,
but for your butt?
"Mmm...?"
Where you're just like,
"Oh, someone's got
a little toot today."
You're right.
I didn't think of it like that.
"Well, when you say it
like that, --..."
(laughing)
Yeah, I mean,
there are some...
some where you're just like,
"I'm so glad no one else
was around to...
Like, I'm glad I didn't
let that one out like an SBD.
You know, where you're like,
"Oh, it won't smell that bad,"
and then
you're like, "Oh, dear."
Do you... yeah, do you ever think in your head,
you're like, "I know this
isn't gonna smell..."
Yes.
...and then you have to
start pointing
to the...
kid on the train?
Oh... oh, you, you do them...
Do you let 'em loose
on the train?
Yeah, I have to, 'cause if
I don't, I get a stomachache.
You ha...
What?
Oh, well, guess what?
Screw you, Ian.
Suck it up, literally.
It's a train!
The train stinks!
I mean, unfairness,
if anyone farts on the train,
they're probably gonna think
it's Ian.
That's a good point.
Yeah, 'cause I look
like a fart.
You've gotten blamed
for a lot of farts that
weren't your responsibility...
I might as well
toss it out there.
...so now you might...
might as well get 'em out.
You're like a fart
with a face.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, that's so true.
Thank you.
I'd be like, "That guy just...
"That guy gets stomach issues
if he doesn't let 'em out...
Yeah, people love farts,
so people love me
...so I'm gonna let him do it."
By the way, you're not
some... this isn't
some unique quality
that you possess
because you get stomach
cramps if you don't fart.
We all do,
but we hold them in.
I mean, I was br... I was
being brutalized on the train
by my own digestive system...
Where?
...or on the, um,
on the plane yesterday.
But I knew letting it out
would make everyone suffer,
so I suffered
silently.
So, why didn't you go
to the bathroom then?
I did eventually, and, um...
Yeah.
Yeah, and I let out, but,
like, you know, because...
a, a lot of being on a plane
is not being able to get up
and go to the bathroom.
Right.
Either the people
next to you are sleeping
and you're waiting on that,
or there's turbulence
and they put the sign on,
and then you're the --
who gets up and makes
a big commotion...
Mm-hmm.
...or you're landing,
or you're...
there's a lotta rules
when you fly...
um, so you can't
time it perfectly,
but I've let 'em sli...
I fall asleep
and sometimes they slip out.
It happens.
That's when it happens.
And that's when it's like,
I feel so bad.
Yeah.
And what do you do?
Do you... I don't...
I just pretend to be asleep.
You're asleep.
How do you feel bad?
Oh, you...
wait, wait, you're falling...
No, it'll,
it'll wake me up.
(laughs)
Do you...
What are you, a dog?
Yeah, yeah, totally.
Oh, that's happened.
(laughing)
I love that,
that's so funny.
I would, I get woken up because I...
of the embarrassment
more than anything,
'cause you just realize
where you are
and who you've just
done this thing in front of.
I don't have enough shame
for that.
Ugh.
I don't think
that would wake me up.
Oh, yeah.
You know, you know how parents,
when they have a new kid,
they hand out candy with, like,
a little letter to, like...
Oh, yeah, like on the plane?
"It's our son's first flight.
He's gonna be yelling."
I'm gonna be do that,
but for my stomachaches.
Oh, my God,
you just have, um, uh...
What, what could you give
someone to put over their face?
Like, an air freshener?
Like, one of those sort of...
full masks?
Like, one of those face masks,
but it's like...
Yeah.
Yes!
Oh, my God, that's so...
and just quietly hand it
to everyone in your...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
like, behind you,
in front of you.
"I had
a lot of coffee today."
(laughter)
That is so funny.
Oh, I was, like, putting down
some broccoli one...
My mom, like,
made me all this broccoli,
'cause I eat veggies
all the time, and I was...
My dad was watching me
eat before a flight
and he was like, "This is
a crime what you're do...
(laughter)
...what you're loading up,
like, this is..."
It looked like I was,
like, trying...
like I was about to do
a prank on a plane.
(laughter)
Like, that was how much
broccoli I was eating.
It's like bioterrorism.
It really was.
It was so...
it was so much, yeah.
Now we're gonna have to
arrest your ass.
Yeah, I did
a "Hiking with Kevin."
Um, you can go check that out.
It's on Kevin Nealon's
YouTube channel.
But at one point he was like,
"Have you farted on this hike?"
And I'm like... "No."
And he's like,
"Do you want...?"
And I'm like,
"I don't even think...
"I'm sure I could, but I think
my body shuts down,
and it's like, well, no farts
are coming out right now."
Mm-hmm.
When it's...
When you know the com...
Like, right now
I couldn't fart,
even though I probably have
so many farts in me.
I've had coffee,
I ate a lot last night.
(laughs)
Got a couple
in the chamber.
I chewed a lot of gum this morning too.
Like, every...
Gum?
Oh, gum makes me
fart like crazy.
It makes everyone fart, 'cause
you, like, breathe in air.
Oh, wow.
And it's that
fake sugar.
Otherwise,
she's not breathing --.
Yeah.
(laughter)
It makes you swallow air
is what I meant to say.
What have I taught...
thank you for catching that.
No, it makes you swallow air
and it has the aspartame in it,
which makes me...
like, the sugar-free stuff?
Mm-hmm.
Oh, yeah.
That gives you disgusting farts.
Like... farts made in a lab.
They're bad.
Those farts kill rats
in a lab.
Yeah, do you ever eat
sugar-free stuff, Myka?
I, I used to, I, you know,
I grew up in the '80s,
so that's all we ate.
Yeah, I mean,
the... it's disgusting.
Yeah.
Those farts are really
disgusting.
We gotta move on
from fart talk, it's
kinda grossing me out...
(laughs)
...and it takes a lot
to gross me out.
Hey. Hi.
Kerryn Feehan
just walked in the door.
Sorry I'm late.
Um, we are not sorry
that you're late...
(laughs)
...because you sent us
a picture of your ass
in consolation.
Yeah, thank you.
So, Kerryn was running late
today and she, um, texted Myka.
She was like, "I'm running late,
the train, whatever."
(Ian)
And me.
And Ian, and, um, and said, "Show this to everyone."
Like, as a consolation prize,
and it was a picture of her,
um, taking a selfie in
the mirror with her fine ass.
Thank you so much.
Your fine, naked ass.
Is this the hot girl
side of the table?
Oh, yeah.
(laughing)
We'll get Myka over here.
Hey, what?
I'm a hot girl.
Okay, you are.
Some days you are.
(Ian laughs)
I'm a hot bitch.
Yup.
Uh...
How was, uh, everyone's
weekend, guys? Good?
Great.
Yes.
Did we have good times?
Any good stories come out of it?
Anything of note?
I was in Phoenix, had a lot
of Squirt Nation come out,
shout out to Anushka...
Nanushka.
You said I wouldn't remember
your name, and I didn't.
Yes, I did. Anushka and Ali.
Yeah.
and then that tall black man
who was super nice
but I forget your name.
Uh, he was a listener
to the show, really nice guy,
forgot your name,
but I did ask for it,
'cause I was like,
I was gonna give you a shout-out
but I didn't remember it.
After Anushka... I had to
commit that to memory...
Yeah.
...and then I lost yours,
and then another guy
that I only remember your name
because you messaged me later,
Peter is also a listener.
Thank you for coming out.
If you come to the show
and you listen
and you tell me your name,
I will give you
a shout-out on Monday's show,
uh, generally, if I remember.
But thank you for listening
and thank you for coming
to those shows. Um...
Yeah, I'm...
If it was a tall black guy
in Arizona,
it had to be a Phoenix Sun.
(laughing)
Yeah. Yeah.
'Cause there are...
those are
the only black people
in the entire state.
It was a weird...
Phoenix is hot...
Yeah.
...and weird, but it's... it was
good, it was a fun time. Yeah.
Nice.
Andrew and I
had a good weekend.
He... I... oh, man,
he is on a plane right now.
He got stuck on a...
(laughing)
We got the wrong...
we booked the wrong ticket home.
I booked the wrong ticket home.
So, I was supposed to leave
at 1:20 in the morning
after our shows...
like, we were supposed to go
right from the shows
to the airport.
(Ian)
Uh-huh.
I was like, "Oh, my God."
I, I loved it.
I was like, "I don't have to
go back to my hotel room."
It's perfect.
And then wake up at 7:00.
Yup.
It's just, like, on.
I was so excited,
and then I looked at my ticket
just to be like,
"Wait, where are we sitting?"
In between the shows.
And I realized
it was for Monday morning.
Oh...
And I was like, "Oh, no,"
and I, I called Jenn,
'cause Jenn helps me with
this kinda stuff on the weekends
when she can, and I called
Jenn, our producer,
and she fixed it,
but, um, it... but An...
Jenn...
But got Andrew stuck.
...we couldn't get Andrew
on a different flight,
so Andrew kept that flight.
He had to stay in Phoenix
yesterday all day.
Oh, no.
(imitates, nasally)
"The snake on a plane."
Oh, my God, and I was, like,
"You should do something
with your day.
"Go out and go to a...
"Uh, there's spring training
happening there, like,
at the stadium right across
the street, like, there's..."
Oh, that's so fun.
...and we made friends
with local comics.
Right.
Like, there were people that
wanted to hang out with him,
and he just...
yesterday, all he did
was sit in the hotel room
all day.
He's like, "I went to the...
I went to the pool
for 15 minutes and..."
(laughter)
That was it.
Like...
I, I just...
I worried about him.
"I dunked my sandwich
in the pool
to get it wet
so I could eat it."
(laughter)
"So it was mushy
so I could chews it."
Chew, chew... I said chews it.
Chews it?
Oh, my God, he is saying,
"Huh?" so much,
and he's got me saying "Huh?"
instead of "What?"
or "Could you say that again?"
or "Pardon?"
Oh, no.
"Huh?"
We were doing...
Ugh.
That is not the direction
that the influence should go.
(laughing)
I know.
He should be
getting funnier
and more erudite.
Not cool.
I am saying, "Huh?", he...
'cause I call him out
every time he says it,
and then I started saying it...
Oh...
...and it is, it is an epidemic.
Yeah.
"Huh?"
Oh...
Like a donkey.
It is so bad.
Uh...
I used to, I used to get...
made fun of by my family
for saying, "Wool..."
instead of, like, "Well..."
I go, "Wool..."
Oh, that's a good one.
"Wool..."
Yeah, yeah, you do say that.
"Wool, you don't know."
My dad used to make...
get mad at me
'cause he used to...
'cause I'd go, "No... ah."
Oh, yeah.
And he'd go, "Noah's Ark?"
(laughter)
So I always say your name.
He goes, "Why you
bringing Noah into this?"
I'd be like,
"I hate you, Dad! No... ah!"
Um...
(Kerryn)
Dad burn.
(Ian)
That's great.
So I was saying your name all...
Noah, I was saying your name
my whole childhood.
Hmm.
Um, yeah, it was, uh,
it was a good weekend of shows.
Yeah, someone, um...
Apparently, someone's
pretending to be me on Facebook
and has started an account
that looks exactly like mine...
- Oh, Myka...
- ...and is messaging
a lot of my friends.
-You caught me.
Good for you.
-Myka...
-I'm getting so many followers.
(laughing)
She's caught.
And someone wrote my dad,
and then my dad wrote me.
-Nuh-uh.
-He'd be like, "Is this you?"
And I go, "Dad, why would I
talk like that?"
It sounds like someone
who's learning...
It sounds like a bot, you know?
-Yeah.
Like, and there's... like,
"I sincerely appreciate
you writing me, good sir."
Like, it's, like, that.
-No...
-Wow.
And my dad was like,
"Is this you?"
Have you seen the movie "Us"?
-Not yet.
-No, not yet.
Oh, boy, that sounds like
it's from "Us."
-Doppelgangers, right?
Oh, like someone kinda being you
but not you.
Uh-huh, yeah.
Cool reference, though,
nobody can get.
-Yeah.
-You know what, Kerryn?
-- off, all right?
(laughter)
It's the new Jordan Peele...
- Yeah.
-...movie that everyone saw
-I saw it Thursday
-This weekend.
and it was really good.
Yeah, everyone saw it.
Everyone...
Keep bragging about having $13.
(laughter)
I get the senior tickets.
You -- would.
-Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
-You Dreyfus.
-Ian does get...
-First seating in airlines.
-Yeah.
-Dreyfus.
One time I was on a date
and, uh, they caught me...
-With a what?
-And it, it was... yes.
Look at him
bragging and bragging.
-Yeah.
-I know.
And, uh, and she lost
her --... on them.
She was like--
'cause I was like,
"My grandmother
bought me these tickets."
-Oh, my God.
-So you bought the senior
tickets online and then when you
met them in person
and the ticket tearer was
like...
They were, like,
"Hey, it's a senior."
And I was like, "Well,
you know, my grandmother."
You took a date
on a senior discount?
I know, isn't that insane?
Why didn't you just bring out
the Entertainment Book
of Coupons?
-Right.
-I know, it's really...
-You -- cheapskate.
-What do you want from me?
But then, Myka,
his date defended him.
Yeah.
...and was like,"His
grandma bought these!
-Yeah
-"His grandma bought these!
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah, it was, it was a...
Which is an insane thing, that
your grandma would go online
and buy you tickets...
-Well, my  grandmom's dead,
...for your date.
so... all my family's dead, so
it was a lie to begin with.
That was a really good
impersonation
of your tranny date.
(laughter)
What was...
it was one of my girls,
and the, the fella
really came out.
Yeah.
(laughter)
I mean,
it was a real 'tude, dude.
(laughter)
I was like, "I've never seen
this side of you before."
What would it be like?
Yeah.
"I hope to later tonight,
but, uh..."
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Please.
He's got
his mustache ready.
Ian Fidance is here.
-Yeah.
-Myka Fox is here.
Woot-woot!
-Kerryn Feehan is here.
-Woot-woot.
Uh, you can hear
their podcasts...
What is your podcast,
you guys?
-Oh, it's defunct.
-Oh, never mind.
But you should still...
Well, you can listen
to Ian's podcast,
"Ian Fidance's Wild World."
Yeah, well, I got a new one:
"Sex Ian the City."
Yes, "Sex Ian the City,"
in which you lit...
-Yes.
-Oh, shut up, Ian.
...watch "Sex and the City."
-Yeah.
-You, you made a podcast
just for a title?
I... no.
I've never seen
"Sex and the City..."
-Yeah, which came first?
My buddy's seen every episode,
and I've always kinda hated it,
We're rewatching it, and I...
And what are you on right
now?
...loves it, uh...
-Yeah, isn't it great?
-Uh...
Are you Aidan or Big?
I haven't gotten
to Aidan yet.
-Oh, --.
-We're just on episode 106.
-Oh, wow.
-But we have
real bad ADD,
so we have a hard time
sticking to the episode.
-I, I was reading
the reviews of your ep...
of your podcast,
'cause you had posted some.
-Uh-huh.
-People really seem to like it.
But people are like, "Uh, you
don't even talk about the show."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I could tell.
-Yeah, it's very fun.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Um...
What are... do you...
what, what are your...
what's your takeaways
from watching six episodes?
Uh, I -- love Carrie.
She smokes indoors...
-Yeah.
...um, and I wanna be
as cool as Big, and, uh...
I want that for you too.
-Yeah? Thank you.
I don't see it
coming even close.
- Who were you guys into?
- No?
-Oh, on the show?
-Mm-hmm.
-Big, a thousand percent.
-Really?
I hate Miranda.
-Oh, yeah.
-I like Big. Why?
I can't stand Miranda.
Most people are not,
like, into her.
Yeah.
Because she's the only
believable character
on that show.
Why, 'cause she wears
-- collared suits?
No, 'cause she makes sense.
Everyone else is acting
like an idiot all day.
Yeah, that's a good point.
-She's not as interesting.
- Like, Samantha's over here
putting, like,
pineapple on her --
and making people, like,
turn it into a soufflé.
I'm like,
"I don't know what happening."
Yeah, yeah, she's...
Actually, no, no, no.
I don't like Charlotte,
that's who I don't like.
-Well, yeah.
You know what I don't like
is that they're selling us
that any of these women
are friends...
...outside of their connection
with Carrie.
-Yes!
-Right.
Like, when they do a
Charlotte/Samantha storyline...
No way.
...where, like, they care
about each other, I'm like...
-No.
-"...Yeah, right."
Oh, I haven't gotten
there yet.
If Carrie's going, like,
"Hey, Samantha,
let's go to brunch,
Charlotte's coming,"
Samantha would go,
"I'm gonna...
-Yes!
-...bail out, honey."
(laughter)
Yeah. Yeah.
-In a heartbeat.
-Right.
She would never hang out
with Charlotte, ever.
-No. No.
-Miranda and Samantha
might get along.
Like, I could see those two.
Charlotte is a bummer.
Yeah.
No one would ever be
friends with her.
She sucks,
she would only be friends
with people exactly like her.
She would never be friends with
someone as cool as, uh, Carrie.
-Right.
-She's a, she's a bummer.
She thinks everything... she's,
uh, uptight about everything.
Yeah.
And she doesn't like to, like,
really share much about herself,
which is what you look for
in a friend,
is someone who's, like...
lets you share
a lot of weird stuff
and doesn't judge you,
and also shares weird stuff
about herself.
She's a, she's a...
the worst.
She's that
New York archetype, though,
that had to be
in the script, though.
Yeah, it makes sense
why she's in it.
She was that, like...
little princess.
But she would never be
friends with any of them.
I dug, in, like,
one of the first episodes,
how, uh, Samantha was like,
"Have sex like a man."
And then Carrie has
some guy go down on her
and then she was like,
"Okay, go."
(Kerryn, laughing)
Right.
"I'm gonna smoke
a cigarette."
And I was like,
"Yeah! That's my ideal day."
-Yeah...
-I relate to Samantha
'cause she refuses
to get an AIDS test.
(laughter)
Oh, you pulled a Samantha?
That's... yeah...
the, um, "Act like a dude."
Just, like, have a guy...
That's what the...
there used to be, like, um...
I heard a story
about Britney Spears,
that she would just, like,
have guys.
Like, she would pick out
a guy at a dance club
and they'd be like, "Miss Spears
is waiting for you."
Oh, no, this is...
-Oh, I love her so much.
-What?
-That is so hot.
-I heard a story about a, um...
This is what I was ins...
I was talking
about the Britney thing
because I heard, um, s...
I forget who told the story,
but it seemed
really trustworthy,
that a certain
singer-songwriter-actress
that we all know was...
had a party at her house,
she had just broken up
with someone after a long time
and had this, like, party of...
like, a coming-out party,
like, "I'm out of this
relationship," and, uh...
Oh, I remember who told me now.
So then, she's, she meets this
guy, they have a good banter,
he... all of a sudden
she's gone,
and her assistant come up
to the guy and goes, "Um, she's,
uh... Miss Blah-blah's
waiting for you upstairs."
-And she's like...
-Ah...
It's, like, at her house
that the party's going on.
He goes upstairs, they bang.
(gasping)
-And then...
-I love it.
...he... and then, uh...
I, I think this...
This is what happened
with Britney Spears.
Britney Spears used to do this,
and summon guys
upstairs or whatever.
Like, her assistant
would just get them
and tell them to arrive
at the house or whatever,
then they'd be brought up,
and then they would bang.
Britney would go to the
bathroom,
you know, like, as you do after,
you go to the bathroom,
and then the assistant would...
she would text her assistant
from the bathroom,
like, "Get him out..."
(gasping)
...and the assistant would come
and go, "Miss Spears, um...
your car is ready, sir."
Oh, my God, I love it.
-"Your car's ready."
-And she would never even...
She would never... this would
just be during the day.
She would... he would be
brought to her house,
like, she would, like...
- Oh...
- During the day.
- ...ask...
Or whatever.
-I love it.
Like, she wanted to have sex,
she would ride a guy, come,
go to the bathroom,
then text her assistant,
"Get this guy outta there."
The guy would be gone by
the time she went back to bed,
so she would never
have to say goodbye...
she would never have to
do any of like, the...
-Oh...
-That sounds awful, actually.
-I love it!
-I kinda love it.
If it was me, though,
I'd be like,
"Miss Feenan is waiting
for you at a bus stop."
Yeah.
(laughter)
I, like, wouldn't be,
like glamorous-- I love it!
"Your Uber pool is here."
-Right, I love that power.
-I really...
I think if I could do that,
I would do that.
That... Motley Crue
used to do that.
If I didn't have any of the...
'Cause sometimes..
I just wanna... Sometimes
I... you know.
It's, like,
such a rock star move.
To just, like...
I don't like the after stuff.
I don't like...
sometimes even during sex,
I would like to text
my assistant and be like...
-"Can you get him out of here?"
-"Get him out."
"Can you get him
out of my --?"
"Yeah, can you ask him
to leave?"
"Can you pull him out?"
(laughing)
-I think it's just so brilliant.
-I love it.
Then you don't have
any of that awkward...
I mean, I'm sure guys
do this all the time.
Male celebrities are getting
their assistants...
-Yeah.
-...to get rid of bitches
constantly.
Derek Jeter used to give,
like, a gift bag.
-Yeah.
-I've had guys, like,
make me a cup of coffee
at 2:00 in the morning.
I'm like, "Wait a minute."
(laughter)
"Sorry, honey,
this ain't a sleepover."
"I have to go now."
Oh, my God.
"You don't have to go home,
but you can't stay here."
-Coffee.
Guys get so weird after sex.
-(Ian) Yeah.
-They really...
- I, I really avoid it.
-Yeah.
I avoid sex
'cause I don't wanna fart
and I avoid it because I don't
wanna see them change afterward.
Do you kiss on the mouth
after a hookup?
Um, I, yeah, I would, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, why?
I always think that's
like a test, I don't know.
-What?
-Like, I think, like,
it wouldn't, like...
-Oh, like, kiss goodbye?
Yeah, like a kiss goodbye.
Sometimes guys
don't wanna... yeah.
Like it's
too romantic now.
Yes, it's too romantic.
We just...
banged and it's over.
Guys are always trying
to make out with me
after they go down on me
and I'm like,
"Ooh, I know what
that smells like. Get out."
-You don't do it?
-Jesus, Kerryn.
I mean, I will, reluctantly.
(laughs)
-What? I freakin' love it.
-I mean, in fairness,
I smelled Kerryn's chair,
so I don't blame her.
Uh, no, I'm like, I'm like,
you know, "This is like...
I just took a spin class, bro.
I mean, it... maybe it's
good for you, but..."
Even if I'm not, like...
-Ugh...
-...as fresh as a daisy...
(laughing)
First of all,
no guy's going down on me
if I'm not fresh as a daisy.
-Oh...
Like, I would, I would just
be like,
"No, you're not allowed
to do that."
Are you kidding me?
I'm like, "Clean it up.
I mean,
it can't stay gross forever."
Like,
"Can you get that lint?"
(laughter)
-I love...
-We're gross.
...licking a guy's face
after he goes down on me.
Me too.
-Love... it.
-No.
I am like a golden retriever
who hasn't seen his owner
after he's been at war.
(laughter)
I'm like...
(panting and yelping)
Like, I pull them back up.
I love it.
I'm like,
"It's me, it's me."
(laughter)
Oh, my God...
That's, like,
the only way you could ever
go down on yourself, kind of.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I love it.
I used to... I remember
the first time a guy did it,
I was like, "Oh, God!
Good night, sir!"
Like, I was disgusted
that he would even try,
and then I...
now I've... I love it.
I guess it also depends on,
like... it was like...
if it's the first time,
I'm grossed out.
Like, once I start
liking a guy,
then I can, like,
get into it.
-But it's your juice eitherway.
-Yeah. It's so good.
I know, but, like, the
first time, I'm like,
"We're really
that comfortable already?"
I don't know.
(Nikki)
Yeah, I guess it is...
No, I...
what it is, it's like a p...
what's good for the goose...
It's like, that's how you know
whether or not your -- stank.
And he's trying
to let you know.
-I know. I'm like, "I get it."
-Yeah.
I'm like, "You were
down there for a while."
No, we figure it out
beforehand, though.
I feel... do you really?
And if it's bad,
we're not... yeah.
Do you.. how do you,
how do you know?
You do a little tip test.
I don't know,
I've had guys pull off my pants
and go right to it,
and I'm like, "That...
you should have tested it."
(laughing)
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you test it.
You should have 'em pee
on the PrettyLitter first.
-Yeah.
To check for...
(laughter)
I do feel like...
uh, yeah, I don't know.
Once in a blue moon,
you'll just tear the panties off
and go to town...
-I feel bad when I...
-...but you gotta, you gotta
test it, it's just a...
How will we know if they're,
like... if you're not into it?
Like, how do we know if you're
like, "Uh-oh, this is a bad one.
This one's not right.
Or it is."
You make yourself a cup of
coffee...
(laughter)
You just head out.
Pour a coffee on it?
Gotta go to work."
(Kerryn laughing)
If they come back up for air
within five seconds,
you know, right?
-Yeah, that's a good point.
-That's what would happen.
-Yeah, that's probably...
-But, like, haven't you...
Or if they just, like,
go straight to sex.
Haven't you gone down on a guy
with, like, musk?
Yeah, if they just circle,
you're done.
They start eating your ass.
They're like,
"This is probably better."
(laughter)
"At least I understand
this smell."
(laughter)
"Oh, at least
I understand this."
'Cause you...
I don't even understand
vagina smell sometimes.
-No.
I mean, it's just, like,
"What's going on?"
-But week to week...
-If, if you...
-It's all...
-If I really like the chick,
I, I like her smell.
-Yeah.
-Certain smells.
But if it's just like
a whatever, it's like,
"Uh, you're really..."
That's the only way of knowing
that I, that I would...
Like, 'cause sometimes
you're just like,
"I don't know
what it's like down there,"
and when you lick a guy's face,
you can be like,
"Oh, okay, I could do that."
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah.
Like, I feel like, "Okay,"
that I'm not...
Or you could lick his fingers--
that's hot.
Yeah, yeah, I've done that.
-You know.
-Yeah.
Or sometimes you'll,
you'll peel
the panties off
and you're like, "This is...
Honey..."
-A penis.
Really?
(laughing)
If you're Ian.
(laughter)
"Honey..."
"Honey, yes..."
Oh, man, she's got
some real big clit energy.
Yeah.
(chuckles)
I mean, I've, I've felt,
like, not so fresh sometimes
when I've had sex before,
and been like,
"Don't go down, it's not..."
That's totally fine
to communicate it.
Yeah.
You know?
I'm just... yeah.
I mean, I really feel like,
though...
Well, that's you, Ian.
You would...
What would it take
for you to stop having sex...
once you started?
Fire alarm?
What do we,
what do we gotta do?
Yeah.
(laughter)
At least stop talking
about it.
Some... some sort of
state emergency.
(Nikki, laughing)
Yeah...
Tragedy.
Yeah.
"This Amber Alert can wait."
Yeah, it's like...
I mean, when, when we, uh...
if we blow you
after you've been inside us,
then we're doing the same...
Yeah.
We're licking ourselves
off of you.
Yeah.
Essentially.
Sometimes I...
yeah, I do that.
I really surprise myself at
what I taste like sometimes.
Like, "Oh, it's kinda
like pennies."
Yes, pennies.
Oh, they -- you
in the ass, Kerryn.
Yeah, that's your butthole.
Damn it! Foiled again!
That's what that...
it tastes like iron ore?
Okay.
(laughing)
I've been working on this
new bit about how, um...
you know, I'm tired of guys
fingering us too soon,
like, before we're wet.
Like, it just really...
makes me insecure.
Oh, no.
Well, wait a second...
but that's how you get wet.
No... no...
No, rub my clit
to get me wet.
Rub my...
like, outside my pants.
Yeah.
Kiss me... --...
Oh, oh, okay, okay, okay,
yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. When they just go to
finger you, like, inside...
Ooh.
...and you're totally, like,
dry still...
Oh, like,
before anything... ooh!
Not before anything,
but they make out with you
for, like, two minutes.
Yeah.
It's not enough to get...
I, I need a little bit more
than that to get wet.
Maybe I'm an old bitch,
but I...
and I, and I don't drink
enough water,
but I need more time.
These are the times
we're living in.
What do you do?
Do you move the hand?
Things are fast.
What, what's the move?
If they go in too soon?
No, I just...
I try to will it wet
while they're going down...
Right.
...where, where...
if I feel their hand going down,
I'm like, just like,
"Please get wet," and I don't.
Oh, my move...
I'll just, like, blow them,
and then I'm like,
"This'll give me enough time."
Yup, yup.
(laughing)
That's a good move.
That's a good move!
I do that too,
I do that too.
Why has it gotta be them
doing all the work?
Why can't you hop on top...
Because you guys don't wait
for even me to blow you.
...or -- dry hump
for a while?
Right.
That's the thing, no.
Yeah.
That's when you make the time.
You're like,
"Oh, that sounds great,
"but real fast,
let me blow you,
get the juices going."
Yeah.
You know what?
I don't wanna blow you because
you're not gonna go down on me,
and you don't deserve to be
blown just because you're there.
You don't know that.
I'm so tired... no...
But they deserve to finger you
just 'cause they're there?
Yeah!
Yes.
Or if you blow 'em,
do the move where you
flip around and it's a 69.
Fingering takes no effort.
It is so easy to do.
And it's so hot.
It's super easy.
Girls getting... putting a --
in your head is a lot to ask.
Yup, yup.
No, I agree, but...
So, then, throw your --
on their face.
Hmm...
There you go.
I don't wanna force
someone to do that
if they don't wanna do it.
Can you win at all?
(laughs)
I won't blow a guy till, like,
the second or third time.
And he'll be, like,
coming at me
with that, like,
hard -- in my face,
I'm like,
"Ooh, what's over there?"
Oh, yeah.
I, like, really distract.
I've started rejecting it.
Yeah, I'm like, "Nah."
The guy
I hook up with normally,
he always is just, like,
it's commonplace that it...
we, we make out a little bit
and then his -- gets hard
and then he moves it
up to my head.
Yeah.
(laughing)
And recently...
Yeah.
The other day, like,
the last time we hooked up,
he did it, and I was just...
I just turned my head
like a baby.
Good.
Like on a... I was just, "No."
"No."
Like, I felt like a baby
on the changing table.
What's happening
to these babies you know?
'Cause you know when, like...
I don't know, like, you know
when you change a baby
and they're just like, "No."
"No. No." Yeah.
And you...
I just, I just was like...
with my mouth,
because I didn't say it.
That's why I felt like a baby,
'cause babies can't communicate,
so I just felt like, "No."
"No."
(laughs)
Like, I just turned my head
and pretended he wasn't there.
(Ian)
That's so funny.
I'm just picturing him
whacking your face
with his --.
Like, "Come on, come on."
No, he just kinda moved it
around near it
and realized
I wasn't gonna do it.
Yeah.
I wasn't ta...
I wasn't taking the bait.
Nice.
And so then he just...
He...
like a fish in the water.
He just moseyed on back down
to finger me, and I was like,
"Good job, good job."
I am... I am done
giving blowjobs away
as, like, party favors.
Yeah.
Like, just because you...
just because you kiss me now,
and the next step
is me blowing you?
No, it's not.
Yeah.
It's not.
No, it doesn't have to be
that way.
I mean,
I made such a good film
of me giving a blowjob
that I don't feel like
I should ever have to
do it again.
Oh, my God, where it is...
where is this footage?
I should be able to just play it.
It's on my phone.
You want it?
I would love to
see your styling.
50 bucks, Venmo. (laughing)
(Nikki)
Oh, my God.
Truth in comedy.
It's so weird, because
she's blowing a dude
but you still can't see
her face?
Oh, you can see my face.
You can see
everything too.
I... are you good
at giving blowjobs?
Yes, especially
if a camera's on me.
What's your trick?
(chuckling)
Oh, I know, yeah.
A, a lot of spit...
A lot of self-hate.
Oh, I should pretend
that I'm being filmed.
Yeah!
That would make me
so much better at them.
More into it, right?
Yeah.
'Cause you, like,
worry about your angles,
you do a lot of eye contact.
I do, like,
the edging thing,
where, like, you just,
like, suck on the tip
and keep spinning it, and,
like, just, like, lick it,
and, like, not go full,
full blowjob
until, like,
two or three minutes in.
That is what I've heard,
is that a lot of girls go in
and they're, they're at a ten...
They're deep-throating
too early, yeah.
They're trying, they're...
Too much. No, thanks.
...they come in at a ten.
A lotta guys do that too.
You come in at a ten.
Yeah, yeah.
There's so much to be said
for coming in at a two...
Yup.
Yeah, build up.
...keeping it at a two...
Look at you guys
bragging about -- dudes
with -- long enough
to make a choice.
(laughter)
Myka...
(laughing)
So... I...
sometimes I jerk off alone,
and I can handle my hand,
because I'm so used
to my hand.
I hope you jerk off alone.
I think...
I hope most of the time
you jerk off alone.
Usually alone.
You said,
"Sometime, I jerk off alone."
Well, somet...
I keep the window open.
You never know.
A bird, a pigeon.
A picture... this is like
"Beauty and the Beast,"
and you're like,
"Hello, Belle!"
Out the window.
"Oh, hi, Andrew!"
♪♪
So... you're seeing
someone now.
Mm-hmm.
Um...
you're hooking up a lot.
You're... this is the first time
you've been in...
You're a 39-year-old man.
38 and... and 11 months
in ten days.
20 days.
In 15 days, yeah.
Yeah, so you're... 39.
So, 38.
Okay.
Give or take.
I'd give.
Taking it.
Just take it.
I am.
39.
38.
You're in a new relationship
with a 26-year-old.
27 at some point.
At some point.
(chuckles)
Give or take.
She's 26.
Take.
Give.
(laughing)
39-year-old man dating
a 26-year-old woman.
That means you were a teenager
when she was born.
No big deal.
Um...
I didn't hit puberty,
though, till late.
Oh. Oh, okay.
(chuckling)
Makes sense.
It does make sense.
Um...
I had no pubes
when she had no pubes.
(laughing)
Okay.
Which makes it fine
later in life.
Oh, good.
If there was a point
in your life
where you both...
Where you both...
...didn't have pubes,
then the age difference
does not matter.
Well, there was
a, a year later, but...
A year later you got pubes.
But when she was born...
No pubes.
In the clear.
Straight up.
And turned me on more,
'cause you know
how I feel about hair.
Right, exactly.
(chuckling)
Um...
So, yeah.
So, you're
in a new relationship.
Yeah.
Uh, is she mature
for her age?
She has an old, uh...
(woman laughs)
...soul.
Soul.
(chuckling)
Lot of these young women
walking around with old souls.
She has been...
she's seen things.
Yeah.
You know?
Like Malala?
Yeah, she's, uh...
she comes from the Sudan.
No one says, "Malala's young,
but she's got an old soul."
You only hear about girls
who are Instagram models
with old souls.
For some reason,
we're t... we're... really...
um, celebrating the souls
of all these hot women...
(chuckling)
...to justify why older men
are dating younger women.
"No, but she's, like,
really got an old soul."
But here's the thing.
I, I feel like I have
a very young soul.
That's true,
so you guys, like...
Old...
old face, young soul.
Right, right.
So I think we counterbalance
each other.
So she's telling her friends,
"Listen, he is old, but he has,
like... he's really immature."
"Very old --,
very young soul."
"Super-old --."
"And super-old,
disgusting --."
Mm-hmm.
"Such a young soul.
I mean, this guy..."
Does she compliment
your, um... penis?
No.
She hasn't?
Uh-uh.
She hasn't said
anything about...
Not even on...
She said one time, um...
"Is... it get bigger?"
No, she didn't.
No, no, no, no, no.
She... no, she'll say
it feels good.
She said it feels good?
Feels great.
Yeah, it feels great.
That's nice.
Um... but never like...
"How am I gonna put
my mouth around that?"
Right, like, you would,
you would call her on that
if that was the case.
Yeah, well,
she would have no mouth.
You'd be like, "Well, that's ridiculous."
She would have, uh, just...
Maybe... to get it in her
nostril would be a struggle.
Which one?
She did a lot of coke.
(both laughing)
I don't know, yeah, it's good,
though, I don't know.
It's, it's been fun.
She's cool.
Yeah, the age difference
I don't feel that much.
Right.
I think if she was 22...
There's a difference.
I... you tell me, as woman.
When you're 21, 22,
as opposed to twenty-s...
I think
once you get past 25,
you're getting towards 30,
you know?
Yeah.
Like, there's...
You've been through that
party phase, most likely.
You already went clubbing.
Yeah, I, I don't have
a problem with it.
You're on the tail end
of it.
I don't have a problem with it,
because it is...
It's truly the norm,
that a, a man is 13 years
older than his girlfriend.
It's, uh... that's, that's...
no one would even... no one...
It... that,
that's very common.
Yeah.
The other way around
is not common.
If I was dating someone who was
13 years younger than me...
a 21-year-old boy...
it would be... I would get...
I mean, they would...
I could never do it.
I mean, I could,
it'd be legal.
Yes.
But, like, I would get
so much -- for it.
But here's the thing.
If... you could date
a 26-year-old...
And I know
the age difference,
but I'm saying
no one would care...
I know
you're doing the gap.
I'm 33.
No, no, no... well, 34.
Oh, that's right,
I am 34.
Give or take, give or take.
I was like, "Oh, --.
I usually round up to 35,
to be honest.
When I put it in the treadmill,
I just go 35.
I'm like,
"I'm gonna be there eventually."
There is something
on the tread...
I don't know, someone's
had to have done a bit
where you start...
scrolling.
You know,
when they start at 30,
or they start your weight
at whatever,
and you have to scroll
farther away from it.
I buy your plane tickets every week.
I know how long it takes me
to get to 19...--...72.
(laughter)
'80... I'm an '80 baby,
I'm an '80 baby.
I go scrolling, scrolling, scrolling...
An '80 baby.
Literally, 1980.
Mm-hmm.
'80.
Okay.
What were we talking about?
This is your first
relationship in...
Yeah.
...ever?
Ever, I guess.
Yeah.
As an adult.
And... h... and you're also
newly on Zoloft.
Yes.
And I can't, uh...
come... that much.
Mm-hmm.
But I feel great.
Yeah.
So, it's like a very...
It's a tough dilemma,
because I've never
worked out more,
I've never felt more
confident, I've never, uh...
been more aware and present.
Mm-hmm.
But the penis is a-not,
a-shootin' anything.
Right.
But it still feels good?
Like, you can still...
Ah... it doesn't get to the
point of, like... pow-pow!
But do you feel
the frustration of it?
Are you just, "I can't come!"
But that's the thing!
You don't even feel that.
I don't feel the frustration.
So then, what's...
then, what's...
There...
The only thing
is the other person.
The what?
The, the person.
The only thing...
only thing...
Mm-hmm.
...is the other person's...
if you're feeling bad
for them.
Okay.
I mean, sure, I'd like to...
I gotta say, girl...
we don't really care if...
Like, if you didn't...
But if it never happens?
Mm... yeah.
Then you start to get
a little suspicious of, like...
A lotta girls will go,
"Well, what's wrong with me?"
They'll, they'll put it
on themselves.
Yeah.
I've had that before.
And say,
"It's just your old soul.
"It grosses me out.
"Your -- are fantastic,
they're way up there,
"your -- is great,
but that old soul..."
Yeah...
"That's a problem."
And it could be, you know?
She could just be too wise.
♪♪